[Музика]
знову привіт і разом з вами
Рокссон Іваненко і поло привіт xsara
привіт рік п'ятий тому сьогодні ми продовжуємо
працювати над шкільним життям і
дізнаємося, який ти учень, щоб
Павло ти  подумай, чи ти був хорошим
учнем у школі, я, мабуть, був
адекватним, що це означає, що я був
непоганим, але не хорошим, добре, так що щось
посередині,
я правий так, добре, правильно, хлопці, і ми
почнемо наш урок зі шкільних
жартів, пов’язаних з вами  як жарт у
школі, у мене та мого друга був дуже хороший
практичний жарт, який ми зіграли над іншими
людьми, і він незабаром поширився по
всій школі.
подивіться на дошку, там є дві
половини жартів, і ми спробуємо
поєднати їх правильно номер один Вау,
чому школа була легшою для печерних людей,
що ви думаєте про це, можливо,
тому, що вони були на початку
історії, тож, можливо, там  був  немає історії
для вивчення абсолютно правильно, вони
були на самому початку нашої
історії наступне чи ваш батько
допоміг вам з домашнім завданням, безперечно,
він зробив, безумовно, він зробив, але чи є у
нас тут відповідь, я думаю, що це номер шість,
він зробив усе домашнє завдання  сам по собі
правильно, хлопці, чи трапляється
з вами коли-небудь, коли твої батьки так допомагають,
що вони вирішують, що депресивний,
і легше зробити все самому,
ніж пояснювати це моїй дитині номер три
, є короткий діалог, то що
ти зробив  робити в школі сьогодні ми пограли у вгадування,
але я думав, що ти проходив
контрольну роботу з математики, пам’ятай, що це жарт,
тому має бути кумедний кінець, який, на
твою думку, це складно.
Сьогодні у школі ми грали у відгадки, але
я думав, що у вас є майстри,
це було так, що це було свого роду припущення,
тому що цей учень не дуже
впевнений у математиці, тому це
була гра у відгадки, тому він не робив
жодного перегляду  Абсолютно
так, хлопці, ревізія, чи пам'ятаєте ви, що це
таке, скажімо, дурень або будь-який матеріал z-wave
channel pirate control me, я був
витоком робота, тож, хлопці, я сподіваюся, що ви
ніколи не грали в гру в
лічби, тому що ви повинні бути
старанні студенти, тож іншого, якого ти
знаєш, ти не можеш спати в моєму класі, я знаю,
але, можливо, якби ми були трішки
тихіше, я б точно міг це
статися з тобою, особливо, я думаю,
вранці, Райан, коли ти прокидаєшся
рано і  ти хочеш спати, і
особливо коли вчитель дуже
тихий і спокійний,
ти засинаєш на
уроці, якби це коли-небудь трапилося з тобою,
насправді ні. Я буду дуже добрий вранці
післяобідні уроки, можливо, після обіду
я засинаю добре, я бачу, що я
абсолютно протилежний я вечірня
людина, тому я найбільш продуктивний
вечорами і вночі, тому вранці
я завжди хотів спати і останній
чому Джоані взяла а  Лінійка в ліжку,
мабуть, це єдиний, що залишився,
тому що він хотів побачити, як довго він
спав
абсолютно, щоб ви бачили, що це гра
зі словами, скільки він спав і
скільки ми виміряли відстань і
час правильно, а тепер  давайте запитати у Mr.
По поділився цим смішним жартом або трюком,
який широко розповсюдився в його черепі, тож,
чесно кажучи, я не знаю, чому і як я і мій
друг почали це, але ми сказали, що якщо
ти це був, то ми зробили це  чогось удачі,
тому люди повинні були зробити це, щоб отримати
удачу, тому всі робили це після того, як ми
розповіли історію, ми сказали, що якщо ви бачите
похоронну процесію, це як чорні
машини, які везуть мертве тіло на
кладовище на похорон, якщо ви  побачите, як один із
них проходить повз вас на вулицях, ви
повинні триматися за нашийник, це нашийник,
і ви не можете відпустити свій нашийник,
поки не побачите чотирилапого тварину,
ймовірно, кішку або собаку, тому іноді, якщо
ви в школі, ви не  Ви дивитеся у
вікно, ви не бачите кішок і собак, тому
наші друзі тримали за нашийник
близько двох годин, тому це стало
практичним жартом, о Боже, я не можу повірити,
що це виглядало дивно
тримати  комір добре після тривалого
часу після кількох дайте кілька уроків
вчителів wou  Я був би схожий на стрільців, чому
ви всі дивитеся у вікно, як ви
знаєте колір, це весело, хлопці, добре, так я
впевнений, що у вашій школі також багато жартів,
але тепер нам потрібно
перейти до іншого завдання, яке ми  на
сьогодні, і давайте переглянемо
шкільні предмети, які ми вивчили на минулому
уроці, добре, є всі картинки,
і я впевнений, що всі ви знаєте, що
тут відбувається, це лише короткий
назви предметів, тож що робити  ми
називаємо предмет, який нам допомагає з
числами, складав їх і - в них
один в одного це абсолютно математика
і вивчення іншої
мови буде в нашому випадку англійською
правильним і коли нам потрібно запам'ятати
дати і різні події, які відбулися
вже трапилася історія правильно, і коли
нам потрібно бути дуже активними під час уроку
фізкультури, і коли ми
вмикаємо свій мозок і починаємо працювати
над різними проектами, проектами з
технологіями інтернет-технологій, я бачу, що
так, і коли нам потрібно  займатися
акторською майстерністю і прикидатися іншою людиною
драма
так і коли ми проводимо експерименти,
наука так, і коли ми вивчаємо рідну
мову, українську, добре, і коли ми
дізнаємося про різні місця по всьому
світу, географію і коли ми використовуємо
наші майстерні навички, щоб  створіть щось
прекрасне, це може бути мистецтво чи музика добре,
добре, давайте подивимося, якщо ви
вгадали разом з нами, так що тут у нас
все правильно, дуже дякую,
а тепер, хлопці, давайте подивимося на
це слово, яке може здатися вам невідомим
у нашому наступному завданні, щоб наполегливо працювати,
зірка Босна Чая і гнобливий Атум
поважати Паваротті створити правила історія
про параболу порушити правила
для дефіциту проблема покарання полька
ранія бути дуже добре в чомусь
буддійській проблемі, яка майже зупинилася
за межами зору NASA більше  позитивний, тож тепер
ти повністю готовий
дізнатися про дуже незвичайну школу у
світі, я пам’ятаю, що ти
дуже добре володів географією,  n ти був у
школі,
чи я правий так, я люблю географію так,
ви знаєте, я
завжди пам'ятаю всі ці
складні географічні назви
координати чисел, як це можливо добре,
я просто любив складати шаблони слів, я
думаю, що це називається  семантичні посилання, щоб ви
створювали шаблони у своєму мозку, ви встановлюєте
зв'язки з іншими словами, які ви вже
знаєте, це допомагає вам краще запам'ятовувати,
тому, наприклад, це сучасне посилання, але
ви знаєте, що Amazon зараз відома компанія,
тому ви пам'ятаєте компанію Amazon
і річка Амазонка або ви знаєте, ніби ви
можете придумати таке місце, як, скажімо,
знаменитий вечір, як Нью-Йорк, ви можете
думати про нашу нове думати про нові речі, і
ви пам'ятаєте Нью-Йорк, тому просто встановіть
прості зв'язки з тим, що ви вже знаєте,
я говорю  шаблони, це те, що
я робив правильно, це дуже хороший
спосіб запам’ятати нове, коли
ви вивчаєте щось складне чи легке,
а тепер чи знаєте ви, що у світі є
школа, де  учні
можуть робити все, що вони дійсно хочуть, це
те, що ми називаємо анархією так хаосом, так,
може бути, але учні в цій
школі дуже старанні, як і ви в
географії.
створити
правила для своєї власної школи ви
хочете дізнатися більше про цю школу так
звучить дуже цікаво слухати давайте
дізнаємося більше перше, що я хотів би
поділитися з вами про школи, що в
цій школі вчителі, як Франція для
своїх учнів і  уроки
завжди веселі та цікаві, тому що
всі наполегливо працюють і поважають своїх
вчителів у цій школі, іноді
учні можуть вести уроки, якщо вони
дуже добре вміють щось навчати своїх
друзів про музику, танці та мистецтво,
уроки також можуть бути поза
класом.
будь чудово, ти коли-небудь
думав, що навесні чи, ймовірно,
восени, коли погода все ще гарна, можна
вийти на вулицю і
попити Клауса  він на свіжому повітрі розважається
, це чудова ідея,
і тепер свіже повітря дуже важливе
абсолютно правильно, тому, коли
ми отримуємо більше свіжого повітря в будинку, ми тут, і
є ще один цікавий факт
про школу, що студенти, як я вже говорив
раніше  створюють власні правила щодо
важливих речей і, крім того, вони
обирають покарання для тих людей,
які порушують правила, чи можете ви повірити, що
вони настільки серйозно ставляться до своєї школи,
і вони навіть допомагають школі
вибрати вчителя, який працюватиме в наступному
навчальному році, що звучить  як чудова
ідея, Павло, чи ти коли-небудь чув про
учнів, які можуть вибрати вчителя для
своєї школи, насправді співбесіда на роботу. Я
пішов бути вчителем у школі, як
зазвичай, на співбесіді з учителем,
безумовно, практичний урок перед
нашими вчителями або керівниками  відділу, але
в цій школі вони мали три-чотири
учні, які спостерігали за вашим інтерв’юйованим уроком,
тому це було досить цікаво, і
чи отримали вони оцінку від учнів на
яким, на їхню думку, буде цей потенційний
вчитель у їхній школі, так що
це гарна ідея, яка звучить дуже цікаво,
тому, хлопці, ви можете скористатися шансом і
вибрати вчителя для своєї школи, ви
знаєте, що, я думаю, не було б
школи, домашнього завдання і все  веселощі та
ігри, якби студенти могли вибрати
собі вчителя ні, вони б
обрали мене, а ти, чому ти так думаєш. О,
тому що спостерігає за нами, можливо, хто знає, добре,
а тепер, хлопці, ми дізнаємося, наскільки ви гарні
як студент і  Ви підійдете до такого
типу шкіл, де все
розроблено спеціально для своїх учнів,
добре, хлопці, а тепер чи хотіли б ви стати
студентом горизонтів Громадська школа, чи
хотіли б ви
відповідати за все, що відбувається
у вашій школі, давайте з’ясуємо, чи  Ви можете
бачити, що школа,
в якій написання, названа дешевим легким
шляхом до школи, тому я пропоную вам
взяти аркуш паперу та олівець Буддійська
печера означає арештувати менше паперових
рушників ми робимо вікторину зі мною Свамі
Provo demo, кинь, Ваня,
так що для кожного питання у вас є три
варіанти B або C кожен варіант дорівнює
кількості балів, ви отримуєте один два або
три, будь ласка, будьте обережні, тому що для кожного
питання кількість балів буде
різною.
ppattani це мініатюри стручок ви зваріть
його Akiva три метри вуличного бою,
так що ви готові, містер.  Пауло так, давайте
почнемо добре, тому я опишу
для вас ситуацію, і вам потрібно вибрати
те, що найкраще
підходить для вашого уроку англійської мови, і ви не
зробили домашнє завдання, а
що ви робите.
скажімо, з
географії хто знає, скажіть
вчителю, що ваша книга вдома мм-хм,
і побачимо, що ви скажете мені дуже шкода і
прийміть покарання, тому пан.  По чи
запам'ятав ти кількість балів, які ти отримав,
так, добре, тож ми переходимо до наступного
питання. Ви вводите нове правило у
своїй школі, що вчителі повинні
поважати учнів і всіляко допомагати їм,
щоб усі учні могли покинути школу
раніше  у п'ятницю вдень побачите, що ви можете
залишитися вдома зі школи на свій день народження,
тому я думаю, що це дуже добре
, це дуже привабливо для мене, але з
іншого боку, як ви отримаєте всі
вітання та присутність, і
ці пісні з днем народження від вч
телів  друзі школи так, але
деякі люди дуже сором'язливі, як пан.  Пул,
так що мені соромно, що всі співають з
днем народження, о, я розумію, що ви ма
те на увазі, містер.  Пул, добре, тож пам’ятайте, що
бали переміщуються на запитання номер 3,
ви дуже добре граєте в драматургії, і ваш вчитель
каже: навчите наступного уроку, що ви
робите.
зніміть у класі та йдіть
рано додому, кому все цікаве, і побачите, як
ви кажете студентам, щоб вони написали своє власне
місце та практикуйте їх Я думаю, що
це найпростіший спосіб впоратися з
ситуацією, покласти фільм, покинути клас,
так, але, можливо, насправді не так
залучайте весь клас, оскільки рішення однієї людини,
можливо, вони повинні бути, вони
повинні мати більше навичок командної роботи, так,
можливо, а також це не дуже
поважно, чи не дуже відповідально
мм-хм, тож чи записали ви свої
бали питання номер чотири, яким ви і ваші
друзі допомагаєте  завуч завуч
директор : оберіть нового вчителя для
школи, якого ви хочете отримати на роботу,
і зараз ми дізнаємося, які вчителі такі
учні, як дружелюбний,
тому що це все  Як добре, щоб хороші
вчителі були
найцікавішими та у кого є найкращі ідеї,
дивіться на сором’язливого вчителя, тому що цей вчитель
не буде сердитися на нас, пан.  опитування, якого
вчителя ви б обрали,
дружнього, доброзичливого
правильно я бачу, тому немає варіанту, якщо
вчитель має найцікавіші ідеї,
але це дуже суворо, тому це не працює
так,
так, деякі люди мають дуже хороші
ідеї  дуже креативно, але якщо вони не можуть
донести їх і повідомити людей
дружнім чином, можливо, люди не
зосередяться на тому, що вони говорять правильно,
і, можливо, вони закінчать добре. Я
чекаю, наприклад,
яка година.  урок
закінчити добре правильно і останнє запитання,
а потім ми дізнаємося результати добре
ось ми йдемо
ваш учитель просить вас подумати про
покарання для тих, хто спізнився
чи пам'ятаєте ви покарання в покер Аня,
яка найкраща ідея, на вашу думку
, це  вони повинні зробити додаткове домашнє завдання B
вони повинні сказати, що я вибачте перед класом, і
пояснити, чому вони запізнилися або C,
іноді можна запізнюватися, чому нам потрібно
якесь покарання. У мене був колега наступний
колега, з яким я працював, і вони
зробили  Б  весь час кожен день, і вони
звикли змушувати учнів вставати
перед своїми однолітками і
пояснювати, чому вони спізнюються, це було
дуже цікаво, тому що деякі
виправдання та історії були дуже смішними,
і ви знаєте, хлопці, іноді
ви  використовуйте їх у своєму одязі так, щоб
розповідати жарти, добре, так, я сподіваюся, що
вам вдасться написати всі числа
для своїх варіантів для своїх відповідей, і
тепер ми подивимося на результат і
дізнаємося, наскільки ви хороші як  студент,
тож є ключі до вікторини, якщо
ви наберете п'ять-сім балів, це означає,
що ви жахливий учень, і ви
не ходите в школу, ви не поважаєте
своїх вчителів і, ймовірно,
школа горизонту не
захоче цього  бачать вас своїм учнем, якщо ви
набрали від 8 до 11 балів, ви
доброзичливий учень і хочете насолоджуватися
школою, але, можливо, вам занадто подобається ваша свобода,
тому вам потрібно більше працювати над своєю
поведінкою, а якщо ви наберете 12-15
балів, це означає  що ти молодець  e
зрілим і відповідальним студентом, зрілим
і відповідальним, була Наталія Дорсетт. Я
знімав фільм, Денні, дивлячись на Буч Аніту
і ідеальний кандидат у школу
Mr.  Пол, ти розкажи нам, який ти
учень, я хотів би сказати,
що я отримав 15 з 15, але ти не повинен
брехати, тому я не буду брехати, добре, я отримав
12,
я отримав 12, тому я  Я справді, але ви несете
відповідальність, добре, так що
ви отримали результат, про що було б дуже
цікаво дізнатися, наприклад, чи є ви
гарним кандидатом для вступу в цю школу, чи
є якісь напрямки для покращення,
однак дякуємо вам за участь
у нашій  вікторину, і ми йдемо далі, тому, як
ви помітили, ми говорили про школу,
і, звичайно, у кожній школі є правила
так, дуже важливо дотримуватися правил,
подобається нам це чи ні,
є правила, яких ми повинні дотримуватися, чи ви
чули це останнім  це
ідеальне слово, щоб розповісти про правила, тому
ми використовуємо must у Мерсіні, коли розповідаємо
про правила, давайте подивіться на must, тому ми
використовуємо це слово, щоб сказати, що важливо
або необхідно робити, як ми повинні
дотримуватися правил у  школа не забувайте про те, що
обов’язковість для кожної людини однакова
змінити це
не має жодних додаткових закінчень це просто
залишається обов'язковим для я для вас для них він
вона це залишається однаковим для всіх
давайте подивимося на не повинен тому, коли ми говоримо
про не повинен, це говорить про те, чим ви не є
дозволено робити це заборонено ні в якому разі
ви не можете це робити це також залишається однаковим для
всіх людей, і ми маємо приклад, що ми
не повинні бути грубими з іншими, тому
не добре бути грубим з іншими тепер,
що ви думаєте про  Маючи деякі
практичні вправи так, це гарна ідея
потренуватися тут ми йдемо зараз ми пропонуємо вам
створити три власні правила для
вашої школи, у другому стовпці
напишіть покарання, якщо хтось порушить
правило, яке ви створили тут, у нас є
приклад, який ми повинні"  не називайте один одного поганими
іменами, і покарання, про яке ми думали
, полягає в тому, що якщо хтось порушить це правило
, йому потрібно буде написати 100 різних
приємних слів для своїх однокласників, ймовірно
, англійською так, повинні бути англійські
компліменти англійською так, містер.  По у
вас є якісь ідеї щодо правил
і покарань за них, які ми не повинні
в школі, ми не повинні обманювати чи плагіатувати
чи робити домашнє завдання, копіюючи
чужі наші роботи, правильно це також дуже
важливі речі і за що може
бути покарання  що у вас є
правильні додаткові домашні завдання, це дуже хороша
ідея, щоб більше практикувати і
навчитися виконувати цю вправу самостійно, так що
ви бачите, що для вас є лінія, тож
, будь ласка, напишіть зараз, створіть правила
для своєї школи
та подумайте  про покарання, яке можна
застосувати до цього правила, і, можливо, коли
почнеться новий навчальний рік, ви можете підійти
до вчителя і сказати, давайте виправимо деякі
правила і зробимо наше середовище
більш дружнім один для одного, тому пан.  Пул,
мабуть, сьогодні наш урок закінчився,
тому ми попрощаємося з нашими студентами
і побачимося наступного разу до побачення,
п'ятий рік, до побачення, всі
[Музика]
ви